what I want to discuss a little bit in
this video is the idea of a random
variable and random variables at first
can be a little bit confusing because we
will want to think of them as
traditional variables that you are first
exposed to in an algebra class and
that's not quite what random variables
are random variables are really ways to
map outcomes of random processes to
numbers so if you have a random process
like you're flipping a coin or you are
rolling dice or you are measuring the
rain that might fall tomorrow so random
process you are really just your word
really just mapping outcomes of that
outcomes of that to two numbers you're
quantifying you're quantifying the
outcomes
so let's what's an example of a random
variable well let's define one right
over here so I'm going to define random
variable capital X and they tend to be
denoted by capital letters so random
variable capital X I will define it as
it is going to be equal to 1 if my fair
die rolls heads heads if let me write it
this way if heads if heads and it's
going to be equal to 0 if tails I could
have defined this any way I want to do
this is actually a fairly typical way of
defining a random variable especially
for a coin flip but I could have defined
this as 100 and I could have defined
this is 703 and this would still be a
legitimate random variable it might not
make it might not be as pure way of
thinking about it as defining one is
heads and zeros tails but that would
have been a random variable notice we
have taken this random process flipping
a coin and we've mapped the outcomes of
that random process and we've quantified
them one if heads 0 if tails we can
define another random variable capital y
capital y is equal to let's say the sum
the sum of roles of let's say 7 7 dice
and when we talk about the sum we're
talking about the sum of the
seven let me write this the sum of the
top the the upward facing the upward
face upward face upward face after
rolling after rolling seven dice seven
dice once again we are quantifying an
outcome for a random process we are the
random processes rolling these seven
dice and seeing what sides show up on
top and then we are taking those and we
were taking the sum and we are defining
a random variable in that way so the
natural question you might ask is why
are we doing this what's so useful about
defining random variables like this it
will become more apparent as we get a
little bit deeper in probability but the
simple way of thinking about it is as
soon as you quantify outcomes you can
start to do a little bit more math on
the on the outcomes and you can start to
use a little bit more of mathematical
notation on the outcome so for example
if you cared about the probability that
the sum of the upward phases after
rolling 7-7 dice if you cared about the
probability that that sum is less than
or equal to 30 the old way that you
would have to have written it is the
probability that the sum of the sum the
sum of and you would have to write all
what I just wrote here is less than or
equal to is less than or equal to 30 you
would have had to write that big thing
and if you wanted to write and nu and
then you would try to figure it out
somehow if you had some information but
now we can just write the probability
that Capital y is less than or equal to
30 it's a little bit cleaner notation
and if we now care if someone else cares
about the probability that the sum of
the upward face after rolling seven dice
if they say hey what's the probability
that that's even instead of having to
write all of that over they can say well
what's the probability that Y is y is
even now the one thing that I do want to
emphasize is how these are different
than traditional variables traditional
variables that you see in your algebra
class like X plus 5 is equal
six usually denoted by lowercase
variables y is equal to X plus seven
these variables you can essentially
assign values you either have can solve
for them so in this case X is an unknown
you can subtract 5 from both sides and
solve for X say that X is going to be
equal to 1 in this case you could say
well X is going to be very is going to
vary we can assign a value to X and see
how Y varies as a function of X you can
either assign variable you can assign
values to them or you can solve for them
you could say hey X is going to be 1 in
this case that's not going to be the
case with a random variable a random
variable can take on many many many many
many different values with different
probabilities and it makes much more
sense to talk about the probability of a
random variable equaling a value or the
probability that is less than or greater
than something or the probability that
it has some property and you see that in
either of these cases in the next video
we'll continue this discussion and we'll
talk a little bit about the types of
random variables you can have